geflüchtet vor dem Krieg der Ukraine
über Polen Richtung Küssnacht im Kanton
Zürich es sind krebskranke Kinder die
medizinische Hilfe brauchen
meine Produkt wir sind wegen des Kriegs
und der Behandlung hier
der Krieg hat ihnen jede Sicherheit
genommen im stillgelegten Altersheim
sonerhof finden die Kinder und deren
Angehörige Mitte März Unterschlupf wir
sind plötzlich
sie sind für unbestimmte Zeit hier
dass das für mich zusammen praktisch
Fulltime-Job wird da
ich für meine Tiere mein Zuhause meine
Spielsachen
unterkriegen lassen sich die Kinder aber
weder vom Krieg noch von der Krankheit
er beklagt sich nie natürlich will er
nach Hause aber er versteht dass er hier
bleiben muss ja wir sind stark wir
schaffen alles
ein Leben zwischen medizinischer
Versorgung und Heimweh davon handelt
dieser Film
es ist Ostern die rund 120 Bund
zusammengewürfelten Bewohnerinnen und
Bewohner des sonerhofs sind dem
Bastelfieber rund ein Monat ist
vergangen seit ihrer Ankunft die
siebenjährige amelina mag Ostern und
alles drumherum willst du das nimm es
wenn etwas aus
ich will das hier hast du ausgesucht
lass uns zum Tisch zurückgehen
los oder los los
normalerweise bringt Papa Geschenke wir
essen Ostergebäck und Mama kocht etwas
Feines
der Vater musste zu Hause bleiben sollte
das Militär ihn brauchen an Helena
bleibt tapfer wie so oft seid bei ihr
vor drei Jahren ein Gehirntumor entdeckt
wurde
auf andere Gedanken kommen das tut ihr
jedenfalls gut
die Kinder vermissen ihren Alltag
sie vermissen ihr zu Hause ihre Freunde
normalerweise gehen sie in die Schule
und haben auch sonst viel los
deshalb sind wir dankbar dass die Leute
diesen Event für die Kinder organisiert
haben
freiwillige HelferInnen aus der Region
haben den heutigen Basteltag organisiert
die Hilfsbereitschaft ist immens die
Macht und Sprachlosigkeit auch
Alltag kehrt wieder ein unter den
BewohnerInnen falls es so etwas hier
überhaupt gibt
jeder Tag ist anders aber immer voller
Herausforderungen
lasst uns über den jungen sprechen der
gestern angekommen ist
das Kinderspital Zürich hat den jungen
hierher verlegt in die Obhut von
Alexander Lüchinger der 68-Jährige
Ingenieur hat nach Kriegsbeginn schnell
reagiert und 24 krebskranken Kindern zur
Flucht verholfen
wird er sich auch um diese Mutter und
ihren Sohn kümmern
als Ingenieur hat er viele Projekte in
der Gegend von Shitomir realisiert
westlich von Kiew die Menschen vor Ort
sind ihm ans Herz gewachsen deshalb bot
er an mit einem großen Bus Freunde und
Bekannte in die Schweiz zu fahren auf
der Fahrt zurück von der polnischen
Grenze kam eine Anfrage bezüglich
krebskranker Kinder also organisierte er
einen weiteren Bus
so wie wir fahren euch am Morgen in die
Augenklinik die müssen noch abklären ob
ihr danach wieder ins Kinderspital müsst
das ist noch unklar back to the
kinderspitalordnung das ist das ist noch
jetzt Moment
bitte
sie müssen nicht in die Augenklinik sie
müssen nicht in die Augenklinik sie
haben gleichzeitig einen Termin im
Kinderspital wussten wir das
ich weiß nichts über sie ich weiß nichts
über die Familie das ist das Problem
warte mal
wir haben im Moment ein bisschen ein
Chaos
durcheinander öffnungszeiten
wenn Ali verstönt dass er nicht alles
ganz sofort richtig ist und alles sich
lieblich braucht das am Anfang und das
ganz gut
ist
NASA und das warten müssen sich alle
Bewohner zwangsläufig gewöhnen niemand
weiß wie es weitergeht
es ist Mitte Mai ein Monat ist vergangen
seit nazars Ankunft hier im Sonnenhof
man sieht den elfjährigen Jungen selten
die meiste Zeit verbringt er auf seinem
Zimmer hier ruht er sich aus oder spielt
ohne Freunde zu groß ist die
Ansteckungsgefahr
Nazar hat einen Gehirntumor und ist
dadurch erblindet er darf nichts
riskieren
zum Glück gibt es Lego im Sommerhof
damit hat Nazar ab zu Hause in Lemberg
gerne gespielt
ihr beschwert sich nie natürlich will er
nach Hause aber er versteht dass er hier
bleiben muss
er hatte gerade medizinisch einen
Rückfall aber es geht ihm gut
ja ich mag es hier
die Langeweile versucht Nazare zu
verstecken
ein ähnliches Schicksal hatte
achtjährige Dennis die beiden Buben sind
fast gleichzeitig in den sunnerhof
gekommen auch Dennis hat einen
Gehirntumor ist mittlerweile blind und
wird von anderen Kindern abgeschottet
einen Vater hat Denis nicht mehr er
starb an einem Herzfehler
umso fürsorglicher zeigt sich seine
Mutter
wir gehen zum Rosmarin der Hausmeister
darf uns nicht erwischen
aber nur berühren ein Blättchen nein nur
so okay
nimm die andere Hand hier sind die
Blätter was ist es
keine Ahnung
was ist das Pfefferminz
zu tun gibt es für Dennis ansonsten
wenig
und dann kannst du wirklich
ja warum
es ist sehr langweilig
du verstehst die Sprache nicht oder
ja ich verstehe die Sprache nicht aber
du lernst sie
du lernst Englisch
ja ich lerne Englisch und die Ärzte zu
verstehen oder ja
und ich fühlen uns hier sicher aber
meine Eltern sind in der Ukraine
ich sehe auf dem Handy immer wenn der
Sirenenalarm losgeht deshalb bin ich
immer beunruhigt und ich kann mich ja
nicht entspannen
unter anderem Umständen würde ich die
Schweiz mit anderen Augen betrachten
aber so
sorry
ja Liebling aber wir sind stark wir
schaffen alles haben wir Kraft
zeig deine Muskeln
ja wir sind stark wir schaffen alles
Alexander Lüchinger hat bei seiner
Planung wirklich an alles gedacht sogar
an einen Hausarzt
der pensionierte die die Burkhardt hat
einst in Tadschikistan als Arzt
gearbeitet und dort Russisch gelernt
sich die Zähne
viel
Schokolade Schokolade da
das hatte remotherapie
wie sagt man
danke tschüss
Arena
ein Zahnarzt wird das Mädchen genauer
anschauen müssen
sich
eigentlich ist es Normalos dr Handwerk
und ich glaube das ist auch gut wenn das
ganz normalerweise
aber vorläufig bis man richtig Gutachten
zwei Ärzte und drei Pflegefachpersonen
aus der Ukraine mitgereist eine
Bedingung des Kinderspitals wo nämlich
Personalmangel herrscht
die Kinder sollen einen möglichst
geregelten Alltag bekommen
es ist 8 Uhr morgens Zeit für die Schule
an Helena fühlt sich dafür mittlerweile
stark genug sie hat in der Ukraine die
zweite Klasse besucht Sport und lesen
waren ihre Lieblingsfächer weil sie so
gerne zur Schule ging hat sie sogar
Zusatzunterricht genommen
der Schulbus der Gemeinde fährt die
Kinder direkt bis nach Erlenbach ins
Schulhaus erb
hier wurde eine Klasse nur für
Flüchtlingskinder geschaffen
guten Morgen guten Morgen
Deutsch steht auf dem Plan
heute ist
wer weiß was ist heute für ein Tag
was ist heute für ein Tag heute ist
heute ist Donnerstag
nein nein nein das machen wir nicht
NASA du musst sonst wegsetzen komm
machen wir nicht
Alphabet von euch gar nicht das Lernen
Herausforderung
ja angelina ist auch hier in der Schweiz
eine fleißige Schülerin sie will
Archäologin werden
da kann man interessante Dinge finden
Kristalle Gold
und ich will mal Pyramiden entdecken
ich glaube sie hat
Ukrainisch Programm wo sie Aussprache
nach rund eineinhalb Stunden ist auf
beiden Seiten durchatmen angesagt
Angelina hat in der Schweiz mit ihrer
neuen Freundin Anna eine Verbündete
gefunden
zusammen sind sie stark
und schubst und ärgert niemand
die Schüler haben keine Lust mehr auf
Unterricht dabei steht eigentlich
Mathematik an
muss die Schule die Lernziele wohl
überdenken
aber sie sind
auf Wiedersehen
nicht alle so eine Höfler haben das
Glück in die Schule gehen zu können
Denis bekommt stattdessen Fernunterricht
und kommt dadurch öfter in den Genuss
der selbstgebackenen Torten seiner Mama
die leidenschaftliche Bäckerin hat sich
extra einen kleinen Ofen besorgt
wie findest du den Kuchen
schrecklich fein
Dennis und seine Mutter sind sich in
vielem ähnlich Humor ist ihre Waffe
gegen die Ungerechtigkeiten im Leben und
Erinnerungen geben ihnen die Kraft
weiterzumachen
wir sind alle Kinder im Klassenzimmer
was hat die Lehrerin sich für euch
ausgedacht du hast die Türe öffnen
müssen und dafür ein Schloss gesucht
oder den Schlüssel den Schlüssel den
Schlüssel
hatte so Pech sie war diejenige die
ausgeschlossen wurde
du hast sie quasi gerettet ein paarer
Ritter
Dennis und Ina kommen aus jaraisky einem
kleinen Dorf im Osten der Ukraine dort
lebten sie mit Denis Großeltern und den
drei Katzen in einem Haus mit großem
Garten und vielen Blumen
meine Eltern sind zu Hause sie arbeiten
auf dem Feld und füllen das Lager für
den Winter auf
und warten auf uns
Dennis persönlicher Vorrat
ein Pokémon
es ist Ende Juni über drei Monate sind
seit ihrer Ankunft vergangen heute
bekommen die Sonne Höfler neue Möbel ein
Geschenk einer großen Möbelkette das
bisherige Mobiliar war nur geliehen
einst als Übergangslösung gedacht
und Prinzess Vera
die Freude an der Arbeit ist größer als
der Wunsch sich definitiv einzurichten
die Heimat ist woanders und trotz Krieg
machen sich immer mehr Gedanken über
eine Rückkehr
schon
absoluten ich denke alle die wie ich
zurück wollen haben Angst
vor allem um die Kinder
aber das Herz will was es will
aus medizinischer Sicht wäre an Helena
jedenfalls bereit für eine Rückkehr der
Tumor hat seine Macht über sie verloren
ihr nächstes Emery steht erst in zwei
Jahren an
mein Handy ist ungefähr
am Viertel von
da sind überlegt ja das sind Familien
mit Kind wo keine Behandlungen im Moment
ich habe seit ich selber ich werde
Situation weil meine beurteile ist dass
es jetzt nicht sicher
gegangen ist
mit dir Bewohner ja jetzt neue Möbel
über aber eigentlich Viertel wie Tiger
so wird es Spitzen Widerspruch nein nein
die neuen Möbel lösen kein Gefühl der
Heimat aus
Dennis Mutter sagt etwas ironisch als
hätte sie Zweifel daran
ich weiß nicht
es sind schöne Möbel
auch Dennis und Inas Herzenswunsch wäre
die Rückkehr zur Familie
aber
wir gehen nicht nach Hause
wieso nicht
wir können die Therapie dort im Spital
nicht fortsetzen
die Möbel werden gesponsert für den Rest
kommen der Bund und die Gemeinde auf
Mitte Juli die ersten BewohnerInnen
folgen ihrem Herzen
in 20 Minuten geht es Richtung
Busbahnhof und von dort in das noch
immer vom Krieg dominierte Land
ich weiß nicht ich mag es hier
aber ich will so gerne Heim ich mag
alles hier und will nicht weg aber wir
vermissen unsere Verwandten so sehr
aus einst fremden Menschen sind in den
vergangenen Monaten Verbündete geworden
ich bin traurig und glücklich zugleich
sie dürfen nach Hause in die Ukraine das
ist der Wunsch von uns allen
empfindet und dass der jetzt hier ja
doch also die einzige
und ich glaube es ist so dass die
rindfare Millionen zum Doktor
seit vier Monaten ist Alexander
Lüchinger eine Art ersatzgroßvater für
die Kinder
also
ich muss nicht so gern aber
wie gesagt
auf die andere Frau sieht
das versprochen
für die zurückbleibenden geht das Leben
in der Schweiz mit all den Arztbesuchen
weiter die Behandlungskosten dafür
übernimmt die Krankenkasse
Dennis bekommt zum wiederholten Mal im
Kinderspital eine Chemotherapie
seine Blutwerte sind zurzeit
vielversprechend
wir hoffen der Tumor wächst nicht mehr
oder wird sogar kleiner so dass Dennis
keine Therapie mehr braucht die
Behandlung dauert insgesamt sechs Monate
nach drei Monaten hat er eine
Kontrolluntersuchung bis dahin bleiben
wir sicher hier wir werden sehen wie
sich der Tumor entwickelt falls der Arzt
uns dann gehen lässt werden wir mit
Freude in die Ukraine zurückkehren
dennis ist mit seinen acht Jahren solche
Untersuchungen bereits gewöhnt
seine Krebsdiagnose hat er vor bald fünf
Jahren erhalten
hallo mein Name ist Michael grotzer ich
bin der ärztliche Direktor
wie geht es Ihnen wie geht es Dennis gut
einigermaßen okay ist er
kein Fieber keine Schmerzen
kann ihr gehen
michael grotzer wurde von Anfang an in
Alexander lüchingers Fluchtplan
miteinbezogen er und sein Team beraten
die Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner nun auch
wenn es um deren rückkehrpläne geht okay
ciao
ist sie natürlich immer gemischte
Gefühle oder einerseits
fühlt man sich verantwortlich für
Gesundheit und
Wohlbefinden
natürlich schon
dass Situation von deiner Familie da
nicht perfekt ist ihre Familie sind nur
im Heimatland und das spielte sehr große
Rolle eben gerade in der nationalen
Gesundheit von deiner Kind
flüchten wir reden
mit Hintergrundmusik
die nächste Abreise steht an das Okay
vom Kinderspital hat annelena bekommen
die Situation in ihrer Heimat aber ist
immer noch prekär
Dankeschön natürlich haben wir einen
Plan B
wenn die Situation sich verschlechtert
dann werden wir der Kinder wählen die
Ukraine wieder verlassen
ich habe keine Angst ich will nur zu
meinem Papa in unser Haus zu meinen
Verwandten
in rund 20 Minuten holt sie und ihre
beiden Töchter ein privates
Busunternehmen ab
wo man
die eine von der wichtigsten
Beispiel für alle queschen warum weiß
ich allerdings nicht warum das nicht
selber quasi aber sie hat für alle
question
aber sie hängt offensichtlich Aufgaben
jetzt verteilt auf andere und ich hoffe
es geht auch gut nachher wieder aber sie
ist ein großer Verluste
werden Sie anrufen wenn wir etwas nicht
verstehen holen wir sie sogar aus dem
Bett sie wird keine ruhige Minute haben
Vera ich muss los
Rebell das kleine glücklein
pass auf dich auf und alles Gute
und vielen vielen Dank
wenn ein wenn ich nächstes Mal nach
sitomi komme besuche ich euch
ja thank you bye bye bye bye
ich anderen
okay schönen Abend
und wieder warten die angesagten 20
Minuten werden zu viereinhalb Stunden
der Bus hat vorher noch andere
Rückkehrer abgeholt
Vera und ihre beiden Kinder suchen ihr
Glück nun wieder in der Heimat bei ihren
Liebsten
für alle restlichen sonne-höfler aber
geht das warten weiter auf unbestimmte
Zeit